are you able to raise 75,000 on
Kickstarter in three days for your Space
Command project what was your strategy
when you launched this campaign and then
what did you find port and what did you
find did not work well you know I've
told her 100 scripts all the studios in
the networks and in those cases I didn't
have to raise the money for instance
when I was a producer on sliders with a
22-episode order our budget was 1.3
million per episode I didn't have to
erase that money so although i knew i
could write and i know i can write
direct and produce I different raise
funds before I didn't know if I would
succeed so the first thing I did was I
treated it as a something new I had to
learn and I spent several months talking
to people learning how to do it building
a team shooting the video and really
putting effort into the video because
that would be you know what I'd be using
sure I could do the project and I even
of overworked I didn't know if I could
raise money at all and now we're up to
150 8,000 we still have several week you
know a number of weeks ago we're going
to be having a panel at comic-con so
there's when 158 is not our final number
by any means and so so what I basically
did was I realized I had to treat it
with respect and but I welcome that I
wasn't learning anything but I had no
assumption that I would succeed and
going in with that attitude actually was
very helpful because then it became a
continual learning process and
and then the main thing I also knew was
that you had to be in direct
communication day by day with your
backers with your audience they couldn't
just stop pushing the big red button and
then you know walking away but that's I
think like a lot of people fail
did you research other campaign
sort of due diligence now yeah well
fortunately i run a roundtable of
writers and directors and actors and
producers may be w thursday and we can
do that for 19 years that several
thousand people and so i put out the
word on my table saying if anyone knows
about Kickstarter please send me
information so i got a lot of response
and so I started researching successful
campaigns like Double Fine and some of
the things Neil Gaiman was doing and
then ultimately Neil showed me the
campaign with his wife Amanda Palmer was
doing and so I was learning from that
and and then just kind of course
correcting as I went and some things you
do don't work and some things you do it
did work and and then also you build a
team and so when someone shows up wants
to help first of all you find out what
their skills are and then you say okay
well and see if they're actually going
to do it rather than just
now it's really us also amazing is how
fast everything is there's instantaneous
response and so it could be a 24-7 job
if you let it but you also have to not
get exhausted because you have to keep
up their head to be able to do your job
how much time
last couple months two or three months
yeah and and that was both shooting the
video and also just what you know
reading up on Kickstarter talking to
people learning and but also we actually
launched about a month later than we
intended simply because we had to do
make some fun further tweaks and we were
refining the project because also that's
the other part of it you're also working
on the project as well that the series
of films and you're developing the
concept builds and grows and people will
give you input and then you saw you your
responsive to that it really is a very
direct two-way conversation now the
video is excellent thanks and I'm
wondering how much time you put into
planning that because you have so many
elements that you have the personal I'll
never unas you and other people in your
ensemble then you also have the fun
stuff in the back yes
well it was it was put a couple months
in on on the video and part of it one
thing I recognized with kick started it
was very very clear is that you have to
have the personal touch it's the person
the individual saying hi this is who I
am I really would like your help it's
usually one person whether it's double
fine or amanda palmer it's usually the
one on one unfortunately i was a
commentator on morning edition for three
years long ago and I've done a lot of
media interviews and so I'm very
comfortable with that and I think that
helped but also in my campaign it was me
as a person but it was also this is the
body of work I've done and then the
third part is this is a team I've
assembled and it's an amazing team and
then it was the special effects shots
that we were generating fresh saying
this is what what we're doing is going
to look like so it wasn't just you can
look at our work from the past but
there's no telling what we're going to
do now here's something very concrete
that we generated new specific to this
project and that was very important
because otherwise people are going to be
dubious but if you say okay look look at
this if you like this if you like these
effects shots if you like these actors
who are going to be casting then you get
pretty good idea about what we're up to
how did you choose your incentives that
a long time to in terms of choosing the
incentives we looked at other campaigns
we thought about ourselves as geeks and
what we'd like because I when I was a
kid Star Trek they view the original
Star Trek and I was a huge Star Trek fan
and they were very slow in terms of
merchandising products from Star Trek
initially they're very few and I longed
for different you know model kits and
action figures and 2i phasers and all
that stuff so I'm just kind of thinking
about me as a fan
and and what would appeal to me and what
would I like to have and what would be
interesting and it was a mixture of
several things because I was thinking
about the different kind of people who
would be pledging to Space Command and
so there would be the fans which is
science fiction fans they love to get be
part of this and maybe at a Space
Command watch or Space Command jacket
then there are also the people who might
be visual effects people and maybe they
want to be part of the team or they want
to learn from what we're doing so
there's also the how-to aspect so I
actually posted something called one
minute film school that's about how you
pitch a script how you you know right
write a movie how you direct a movie
with my friends and like you're more del
Toro and my friend Michael making
directs Battlestar Galactica in these
videos talking about those things and
then there's another part of it that
might be aspiring actors who might want
to be part of the project so they might
want to walk on a walk-on role or a
speaking role or there might be someone
wants to have a producer credit and so
they can put money in and get a producer
credit so so I was think about the
different reasons that someone might be
interested in how they might want to
participate and those are different sort
of pie wedges of the whole of the Hopis
and so you have to mind mindful of that
as well there's not one size fits all
you